faire
la voie maritime du saint laurent une
vingtaine de bateaux passent ici chaque
jour des bateaux de plus en plus
nombreux de plus en plus gros voilà à
l'arrière les vagues cet intermède à ses
jours et nuits que ces bateaux là une
passe
micheline lagarde vie à verchères depuis
40 ans
chaque année elle perd du terrain à
cause de l'érosion alors là les vagues
il vient frapper les berges et là ça
file sacré dès ce 9 ans parle de cela
qu'ils avaient été construites par le
fédéral s'est effondré faites donc moi
je n'ai plus aucune protection quand les
vagues de bateaux arrivent et viennent
chercher la terre c'est les sédiments
qui s'en vont dans le fleuve
environ soixante dix propriétés de
varennes de verchères et de contrecoeur
sont touchées par le problème
dans certains cas les terrains s'érode
d'un ou deux mètres par année à cause
des bateaux et des changements
climatiques le long du tronçon darién à
contrecoeur il ya des murets qui ont été
érigés des années 70 qui sont comme plus
laissée à l'abandon qui se détériore
surtout quand au niveau de son os comme
cette année ou en 2010 est à l'époque
lors de l'ouverture de la voie maritime
le gouvernement fédéral avait construit
des murs de béton à certains endroits
pour empêcher l'érosion des berges
mais depuis 1997 si murray sont laissés
à l'abandon par ottawa
il ya des gens là sont dans des
situations d'urgence
c'est catastrophique le y perdre du
terrain c'est dangereux c'est le cas de
la propriété de jacques du rocher sur
l'île sainte-thérèse en face de varennes
une maison ancestrale qui est à quelques
mètres seulement de tomber dans le
fleuve
c'est à 10 et 2 m
pandentaire ensuite la maison bouger de
réunion c'est ça oui il ya des grands
arbres devant la maison des petits qui
dit petit commence à pencher du fou il
fait étrange les citoyens demandent au
gouvernement fédéral qui est responsable
de la voie maritime d'intervenir
on demande qui en face qui est qui et
qui répare les berges
puis qu'ils en fassent un entretien
permanent parce que cette c'est un poids
trop lourd à supporter pour les citoyens
pour accentuer la pression sur ottawa
2300 personnes ont signé une pétition
réclamant un programme de protection des
berges par courriel le ministère du
transport dit être au courant de la
problématique mais estime que l'érosion
est un problème naturel qui dépasse son
mandat à l'union des municipalités du
québec
on déplore l'inaction du gouvernement
fédéral si fédéral veut pas s'occuper de
certains ouvrages qui lui appartiennent
qui a mis en place s'il veut le
transférer la responsabilité mais
qu'elle transfère les moyens au moins de
s'en occuper
si ottawa ne bouge pas les citoyens et
menacent d'intenter une action
collective
il nous ce qu'on veut c'est juste que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
il ya construire mans qui vient juste le
réparer le pire y faire un programme
d'entretien et ça coûterait moins cher
qu'à des frais d'avocat d'ici là
micheline lagarde et ses voisins
continuent de perdre du terrain à chaque
année ici jean philippe robillard
radio-canada verchères